Please welcome.
Dr Rob Silverman
was
better than a,
the one last night,
do you think?
Oh yeah.
Without question.
Genuine.
Yeah.
Much more genuine.
That was good.
You know,
I'm happy my mom wrote that for it.
So why don't we just start off,
tell me about why did you get into this field?
You know,
uh,
it's such a great question because there's always a story why some of them
became a doctor.
It's,
it's definitely not for money.
it's to affect people.
So,
um,
I have congenital torticollis so there's an asymmetry to my head.
You may notice that.
And,
uh,
I grew up in the Bronx,
so that wasn't fun.
That was,
it was a tough growing up with that.
Um,
and the medical model just didn't have anything to offer me and I'm not so sure
they,
they do at this point either.
And I went to a chiropractor when I was 21.
I had suffered a back injury.
And,
um,
I'll tell you,
the mark twain quote comes to mind every time.
The two most important days of your life are the day you're born.
And the day you knew why he moved my metrics so much,
you know,
and I got up and I knew I wanted to help people,
the way he helped me.
And concurrently in school,
I had a business degree.
I mean,
like I think we're all wanting to be a chiropractor,
functional nutrition major.
And I was taking nutrition at the time and I was going through diet and it was
a,
it was an elective.
And in that nutrition diet,
a class,
I learned so much about the Diet and I saw such a change going to the gym and
performing in school and even performing on a basketball court that I said,
you know,
there's something here.
So when I graduated college,
uh,
I took all the prerequisites and man,
I went to Cairo school and I've been going forward ever since.
Uh,
just in this room.
Has anyone here raise your hand if you actually have been to a chiropractor?
Okay.
Pretty large amount.
I would say that,
you know,
going to the chiropractor the first time people are like,
what the heck am I getting into?
You must have had that thought yourself.
Oh,
I never heard that one before.
No,
I'm just kidding.
I hear that all the time.
Um,
and chiropractic has grown so much.
It's grown out of the confines and a context of just,
just spinal work.
But we're well beyond that.
I mean,
and I'm living proof of that right here,
that we look at everything from a holistic approach.
And to coin a cute phrase,
we look at the body from the inside out.
So that leads me to my next question because many people might say,
why does it a back doctor here to talk about nutrition and health?
But you actually have a full approach and tell us about that.
Yeah,
I look,
I look at the body again from the inside out and it was really funny because I
knew nutrition was a key component.
So I'm a believer in manual rehab plus functional nutrition leading to optimum
health.
And I had a really going through chiropractic school,
I had always thought about how do I fix the body from the inside out?
And nutrition was one thing that always resonated as I said with me.
So about 10 years into practice,
I had all these nutrition degrees and um,
I was having some trouble with some patients getting them better and it bothered
me.
So I'm sitting with my six year old niece from Singapore and we're trying to
have an adult conversation.
And of course she's the only adult in the room.
And um,
I basically complaining to her that I can't help somebody and she looks at me
and she says,
you're a doctor,
you're supposed to know.
So I'm like,
and uh,
as opposed to taking it in stride,
I got defensive and I started to make excuses and she just moves a little book
or way.
And she says to me,
you know,
Mommy says,
if you're not good at your job,
get a new one.
So it was a knockout punch.
And then I knew functional nutrition,
looking at the systems are there are only 14 systems in your body.
That's it.
There's thousands of symptoms.
So you had to get to the intrinsic system to really help people.
And that's part of the problem that we have in our healthcare system now.
They're myopic.
And just looking at the symptom.
Why'd you read the book?
You know,
I wrote the book.
Here's,
when I first went to chiropractic school,
I wanted to be,
uh,
help people the way I was helped.
I mean,
that man moved my metrics.
He changed my life and I wanted to change people's lives.
So I became a doctor to do it one on one.
After about 10 years,
I said to myself,
you know,
I want to start lecturing and lecturing to doctors to exponentially reach the
population and that ultimately I wanted to write a book so everybody could
benefit and I could hope to help everybody get good health because health is
wealth.
Well said.
Um,
talk about a little bit more about the issue with the current medical system.
Yeah.
As a referred to,
it's very myopic.
We,
we don't live in a healthcare system.
We live in a sick care system right now,
chronic disease,
which is basically one of the biggest costs on our healthcare system is defined
as something that you have three months or longer that can't be cured by a
vaccine or helped with a drug.
Is that amazing?
So chronic disease refers to cardiovascular disease,
stroke,
arthritis,
depression,
and that's because we're since 1985 we have been led down this road by
pharmaceutical companies.
I call 1985 farm or get in the United States because the US government allowed
pharmaceutical companies to actually advertise to the consumer.
In [inaudible] 97 they said you don't have to list all the side effects.
So that was a very symptom ology move.
We're 4.4% of the population in the world and we use 50% of the forum
pharmaceuticals in 80% of the pain meds.
So there,
you know unfortunately my colleagues look a lot at the symptom and not at the
system and when we start looking at the system and not the symptom,
we are going to start to help people get healthy because chronic disease is
based on symptom system failure.
So the first chapter in your book is something that I think for me it was
something that I had not thought about my gut.
And you focus a lot about the gut being the source of many things.
First of all,
just tell me about what is the gut when we're referring to that,
you know,
um,
it,
it's a great takeaway and that's why I put it in chapter one because do you have
the guts to be healthy?
What have you done for your guts lately?
Did you ever hear the expression gut feeling?
I mean,
we've always known about it,
but we haven't jumped on it.
Our Gut right here,
it protects the inside of the body from the outside of the body.
It's 70% of our immune system is housed in our gut.
It's also where nutrient absorption occurs.
So we have to keep this intrinsic Finn Layer intact.
Otherwise we have all these faulty systems going and we have inflammation auto
immune.
And guess what?
Nobody's really healthy and think of this.
All the drugs adversely hurt our gut health.
So define the gut for me.
Sure.
Talking about with our gut is basically the surface.
Every few we to unravel it of a tennis court with the thickness of that piece of
paper you have in your hand right there.
If I were to take everybody's guts thickness right now,
I mean it wouldn't literally do it,
but if I were to take it,
it would be the size of the head of a pin.
So the gut actually in when it's in pristine working mortar actually protects it
and absorbs nutrients.
So it's what we call permeable.
However,
through stress,
through food,
through non-steroid anti-inflammatories,
which are like Aleve and Advil and other bad pollutants outside our gut now
becomes permeable.
And these food particles which are supposed to be absorbed,
absorbed,
get exposed to the blood system and all our immune system goes on override and
attacks and we start getting autoimmune.
It raises our level of inflammation.
So the first source,
if you could take anything for Monday,
and I'm a big proponent,
when I lecture Monday morning tomorrow application,
start taking care of your guts.
You talk about a phrase for that.
What is it called?
Uh,
all disease begins in the gut.
Poverty's it's pretty smart guy.
And a leaky gut syndrome is something I had never heard before.
Yeah,
leaky gut is kind of like what I was talking about before.
The Gut.
Should be in a perfect position.
So fiber,
to use an example,
think about your kitchen floor.
I think of all the tiles there in the grout,
so your gut should be in that pristine condition.
In this way,
it can absorb all the nutrients it protects yourself.
Unfortunately through,
once again,
nonsteroidal anti inflammatories Aleve and Advil and bad bacteria.
What happens is the grout gets taken out,
it opens up and things pass through.
So a very important thing is we've got a lot of bugs down here.
We call the bacteria.
There's good and bad bugs.
Most Americans have too many bad bugs and not enough good bucks.
So that's why we always recommend a good probiotic.
Probiotic,
pro life,
good bacteria,
good.
By the way,
don't get nervous about bacteria.
It out.
Numbers you tend to want the guy talking to in the street probably wasn't
talking to you.
It was probably talking to his bacteria because it's live and that's his best
friend right now.
Tell me about inflammation.
What is it?
It's a phrase.
It's a term thrown around all the time.
It happens when I bumped my knee.
It happens when I drink too much.
What is inflammation?
Inflammation is the body's response to a foreign object coming in.
So when you've got sir leaky and certain digested or undigested particles come
through,
your immune system goes on overdrive.
So inflammation means to be set a fire.
The biggest problem that we have is please don't be upset,
but everybody in this room is probably inflamed.
So inflammation is the body's response to something that shouldn't be there.
And it leads us down the road for CVD,
obesity,
arthritis,
and for such a young crowd,
early agent.
So typically we treat inflammation with certain drugs and we'll get to that in a
minute.
But,
um,
you have a different approach.
Absolutely.
I mean,
uh,
you know,
the drugs that I like to pick on,
if you will,
if I may are,
as I said earlier,
nonsteroidal anti inflammatories,
uh,
they are Aleve,
Advil,
Ibuprofen,
nonsteroidal antiinflammatories do decrease pain,
but they impair healing.
Nutriceuticals decreased pain,
but promote healing.
Which do you want?
Nonsteroidal antiinflammatories don't allow for muscles to heal,
part ledge,
to heal bone to heal.
And they also cause leaky gut.
And you know how easy it is to get one of those.
I mean,
I travel all the time and when I come to a hotel,
10 11 o'clock at night,
and if I were to say,
if I had a headache,
guess what they offer me?
It's a feeling question.
Tell me what do you think they offer me and sets.
No one offers me a probiotic.
Nobody offers me a fish oil.
Nobody offers me up.
Delight,
delicious,
green drink,
you know,
fiber or no fiber in it.
So the problem,
do they work as well or as quick?
We don't,
they don't work quite as quick,
but they work well without any side effects.
And that's why the American module wants these insights because it's fast,
it's quick and they don't understand.
So if I were to quiz everybody here or survey them,
they would not realize that.
And sats provide no healing.
And so that's referring to Tylenol or Advil,
Ibuprofen and things like that.
Yeah,
absolutely.
So,
uh,
do you have any examples of maybe a patient or something with this inflammation
if issue that you were able to kind of successfully treat?
Yeah,
I'm have many,
but one really comes to mind.
We'll call her Gail.
And uh,
in her teenage years,
she got,
um,
a Lyme disease.
So she got a plethora of antibiotics.
He was gouged with them.
She also did not realize at the time she also had a gluten problem,
gluten being got a glue sticking to the intestinal track.
And then she had multiple other conditions into more antibiotics.
So her gut became compromised so much.
So she had a failed marriage.
She had to quit a job because she had to go to the laboratory too many times and
was embarrassed.
And she basically,
when she came in and early third is beautiful young girl was in a really bad
way.
So we put it through a specific gut restoration program,
took her off gluten and within six weeks she lost the needed wait.
She felt better and she had a job afterwards so it can be done naturally.
And I proport to everybody here,
start considering that the doctor of the 21st century looks for nonsurgical,
non drug approaches.
Um,
little off topic,
but you mentioned gluten.
Is it the enemy that we all see it?
It is absolutely anime literature came out just last week,
so obviously it wasn't able to get it in a book that whether you have celiac
disease are not 100% of people have issues with gluten.
It means glue in Latin.
It sticks.
It's a piece,
the residue.
But it's so good.
I know,
but you know what Jacqueline said about it.
If man makes it,
I won't eat it.
So it can't be good if God gives a go for it.
You say that,
uh,
you also have said to me if it's in a package or the can try to stay away from
it is that,
you know,
it goes back a,
again,
I get to work with a lot of patients and I have my patient come in and says,
you know what?
If it has a food label,
it just forget it.
And,
and the person's right because it's man made.
So the labels can be very,
very misleading.
So let's buy foods without labels.
Let's buy whole foods.
Let's buy real foods.
Let's buy organic foods.
I'm in this room,
show hands.
Anybody that's tried to dye it in the last six months.
Okay.
Uh,
you're not a fan.
Diets don't work as evidenced by the fact that 40% of males in America are
obese.
35% of women are obese.
15% of men worldwide are obese and only 11% of women worldwide or will be,
so we're too heavy.
Diets don't work.
They're a jail term.
It doesn't work.
Therapeutic lifestyle where you adhere to healthy food,
exercise and proper supplementation is the way to go for long lasting weight
loss.
Body composition in overall health.
So we look at a diet generally is a short term thing.
You're saying you should just change your overall lifestyle.
Lifestyle without question.
Uh,
you know,
we,
this is very common.
You go on vacation,
you come back,
what do you,
diet starts on Monday,
you know,
and then you,
you do the cleanse or whatever.
You have said detox and cleanses are very different.
Um,
can you just tell me briefly the importance of detoxing?
Well,
detox is not a cleanse in a cleanse is not a detox.
Basically a cleanse is something you can go up the road and they give you
something and you go to the bathroom real quick.
It's not working.
Detox is something that's intrinsic in that you're trying to detox your liver,
which is in Oregon.
Work through specific hormones were full of toxins.
Every one of us,
this is New York City,
am I correct?
We all walk to get in here,
so we will all expose to secondary smoke.
We were exposed to smoke from the chimneys were exposed to pollution in the air,
was sitting in a a room where they used lead in,
in the paint.
Anybody use any health care products today?
I use nine.
I was the average American,
the average American news,
nine healthcare products that exposed me to 123 chemicals,
which got absorbed in my bloodstream within 26 seconds.
But having,
they've been tested really?
I got a bridge.
It's not too far down the road.
And now what's your thought on that?
Well,
for me,
you know,
one of the things I would do is I would definitely use organic chemical free
products.
I would reduce the ability to be exposed and I would detox.
So I'm a big proponent of a 10 day detox.
Any kind of medical food that has specific nutrients that is enabling your liver
to break down toxins and pass them out through the body.
That's a key component to overall health.
Anybody know anybody that's got rings under their eyes?
Anybody know anybody who's tired,
little upset about their hair,
he need to detox.
It's toxic overload.
You can't be a clean fish and the dirty ball,
uh,
you explain quite welcomed me the other day,
the what's happening in your liver and that sometimes you know,
you're,
there's two parts.
There's what goes in,
there's what goes out and it needs to keep us a solid flow.
Can you tell me about that?
Absolutely.
So I guess you guys are ready for me to get a little technical.
You guys ready?
And if,
yeah,
you please feel free to raise question your,
raise your hands and ask questions.
Absolute take some questions at the end too.
But,
so I'm going to get just a little technical.
Toxins are fat soluble.
They need to get broken down in the liver to what we call water soluble toxins.
The problem in most America is since the liver split in half,
it's called two phases.
Phase one is too quick and phase two is too slow.
Phase one a spot up by people who drink coffee.
By the way,
if you want to talk about a toxin,
let's talk about some coffee here.
Anybody go to Starbucks?
You've got your own.
I noticed that,
but it was with a cure.
I don't tell any of us.
I know coffee is the most drunk consumed beverage in America and it's the third
most sprayed crop,
so you need organic coffee.
Coffee speeds up the first part of the liver to make it move too quick so you're
not able to break down these toxins to begin the get dispensed with to leave,
deliver,
and go to the kidney and go get pooped out.
By the way,
do you know one of the major pathways of the liver is to detox estrogen?
Ladies,
if I may,
the number one toxin that women are exposed to our tampons,
they made a cotton,
the number one sprayed item.
Did I just lose the crowd?
Everybody's looking at it wasn't me.
Don't kill the Messenger.
The number one sprayed item is cotton,
94% of tampons or cotton and they had the applicator.
It's toxic.
So
first of all,
you mentioned coffee.
I mean that's something we all drink.
Organic coffee is relatively okay,
I'm in organic coffee.
But again,
you don't want it in a cure act cause if it's in the Kurek it's got the plastic
because anything with plastic has BPA and bps to decrease testosterone in men.
BPA is also shown to have preterm births in women.
BPA is poison and by the way,
our currency or dollars have BPA in it.
And so do our cash registers receipts.
So we are always exposed.
We own almost need a detox both the spring and fall cleaning.
So I don't want to dive too much into detoxing,
but I,
you know,
I think it's incredibly important and if you guys pick up the book,
there is quite a few examples of,
of solid ways to really pun intended,
to really detox yourself.
Right?
Um,
so I want to kind of skip a little bit more forward.
you talk about,
uh,
a sprained ankle being one of the most common injuries.
Um,
what are we doing wrong in the way that we treat our musculoskeletal system?
Well,
here's your takeaway in your musculoskeletal system.
Number one,
how many of you people have injured your musculoskeletal system and waited to
see if it would go away and heal?
How did it work?
Not so hot,
right?
Cause if it worked,
older people in Caveman would have stood straighter and musculoskeletal system,
which attaches and affects every other system in a body is a unique system in
that it needs some stuff sort of stimuli.
Our bodies,
a beautiful organism.
It has the ability to heal itself.
The problem is it just needs a little help and it needs certain nutrients and
certain exercises.
So typically I have a patient comment after an injury,
like three or four weeks,
and I say,
uh,
why'd you wait so long?
Well,
I want to see if it went away.
Where did it go?
North,
south,
east or west?
Where's it going?
Does it didn't have a passport?
I mean,
where is it going?
And the fact is you all have to know that a musculoskeletal injury does not heal
on its own.
And you have to tend to it with exercise,
nutrition and diet.
Because in injured tissue needs specific nutrients to enable itself to heal.
To speak to the sprained ankle,
it is the most recurrent injury that we have in sports.
80% Reoccurrence.
It's not just a sprained ankle because,
oh,
it's just a sprain.
Tape it up.
But it's not because the current mantra is price pressure,
rice,
ice,
compression,
elevation.
But if that were to be working,
it wouldn't be the most recurrent injury.
So you have to understand that the body's all interconnected.
It's as great working organism.
It's so exciting,
but the bodies and continue connected.
So if you sprained a ligament,
that's what a sprained ankle is.
You've also injured a muscle.
You've injured other structures up above the area of the ankle.
Get it checked.
So when you go to the doctor today,
take some Advil,
stay off it.
Is this,
did you say that?
Did he just say Advil guys?
I mean,
what do you,
what do you do?
What's the better way?
Oh,
well for me simply of course,
seek somebody out.
I'm not going to tell you just to see a chiropractic on a taxi chiropractor.
Nevertheless,
um,
what you want to do is you want to get an immediate treatment protocols.
Some of the things you want to look at are proteolytic.
Enzymes are a much better choice than the end PSATs.
Proteolytic enzymes,
bromelain,
trypsin and Chymotrypsin.
They've natural support to decrease swelling.
There's other items like tumor,
everybody's heard of that curcumin is in tumeric not to get it again,
too technical.
These natural herbs that have been shown to help heal the body at a cellular
level without the side effects,
these end sides do.
And of course,
get your treatment,
get active treatment.
It doesn't go away.
So you actually mentioned in the book that you got to kind of move around a
little bit on it,
right?
You have to,
because otherwise it'll get used to the wrong kind of set,
right?
It's altered motor control and basically your brain is your big chip.
Hey,
we're here at Google,
right?
So you all know how computers work.
The brain is the chip.
So when you're spraying your ankle,
you walked funny,
right?
So when it heals the walk better or did your body feel your brain take a new
motion in movement?
So you have to do something called proprioception and rebalance your nervous
system with your muscular system.
So standing on one leg,
standing on a little unstable surface,
and that will give you a panacea of outcomes that you'll love.
Movement is a great thing that you brought up.
I mean,
by the way,
everybody here is sitting,
sitting is the new smoking.
Sorry about that.
So Reebok did a study.
I'm allowed to say that here.
Well,
Reebok did a study that we live about 26,000 days and in that we exercise 0.7%
of our time.
Yes.
Sit almost 30 and you play with technology.
This may not be news to you 41% of the time.
So do me a favor before I leave,
everybody's going to stand up because at least I know you'll be healthier.
And then you got something from this talk.
So fitbit is a minimum generally of your 10,000 steps,
right?
Does that,
well,
I like the 10,000 step,
but the fitbit just got shown not to work because the people who use the fitbit
didn't work out as hard,
interestingly enough.
So don't use the fitbit but get moving.
If I could tell you anything,
exercise,
move 10,000 steps.
Mike,
what a great start to the day standing desks.
Is it something that helps?
Standing desks are a great choice.
Standing desks as something that I purport to have a habit in my office.
If you ever guys go to my youtube,
my social media thing,
you'll see that I'm standing,
I'm standing all the time.
You know,
I look great for 95.
Right.
So,
uh,
switching gears a little bit,
um,
we have a whole chapter about lasers.
Okay.
So I would have to say that many skeptics,
including myself before even reading this,
I always see lasers as like a quick cheap fix.
You know,
it's going to grow your hair back and do all these crazy things.
But you actually advocate for laser therapy.
Is this correct?
I do.
I'm a big promoter.
It's not just a laser like in the movie,
Austin Powers Laser is actually based on Einstein's Laura physics.
So when you really understand it,
it's basically working at a cellular level.
It's got a light that penetrates the skin and the cell membrane to stimulate
healing at a cell level.
And if we don't think that light is healing,
did anybody ever see a child that was born with Billy Reuben?
You know,
yellow?
What does everybody do?
They put it into the window and the light.
So this is mimicking the sunlight to allow for healing from a guest.
What?
From the inside out.
So,
um,
a couple of quick things now.
Uh,
switching from lasers,
concussions,
the same thing that you actually write about also in the book.
That's,
you know,
I think kind of interesting.
It's certainly on the rise.
Tell me about the epidemic anyway.
Concussion is probably the most topical conversation we can have,
but you know,
it's interesting.
I'm going to ask the crowd what sport has the most concussions?
Soccer.
It's number three.
Good guests.
Football number two.
Number one,
cycling.
Now cycling's number one.
Wow.
Football's number two.
What do they both wear?
Helmets,
right?
So what does that tell you?
The helmet is there so they don't crack their skull.
So let's understand what's going on because it's rampid concussions it.
Your brain is three pounds.
It's small.
It's three pounds of jelly hold by one septum.
So it's not the initial impact you.
So if I go like this,
it's not the impact.
It's the whip.
And when you whip your head,
you stretch your brain tissue.
They're showing that people are stretching this gelatin the substance up to 50%
so if you may remember the Jello your mom gave you spread it apart,
50% that's where that brain injury occurs in the problem that we have is that
90% of people have a concussion,
do not lose consciousness.
So people don't think they have a concussion.
Concussion is running rapid.
It's on the rise.
Most common,
believe it or not in females.
And the reason real simply is women have a tendency to report injury quicker.
Number two,
women's next aren't as strong as men.
And they whipped her head back.
And number three,
they have something called the withdrawal hypotheses.
Women have estrogen and then progesterone during their normal cycle.
So progesterone in the last two weeks is typically high.
It has a calming,
healing effect on the brain.
The moment the woman gets hit,
the pituitary gland struts to purchase,
thrown off.
They have no hormonal response and they are more susceptible to concussions than
men.
So you advocate for a different type,
a different approach to treating concussion.
Absolutely.
So what you know,
there's a lot of people out there saying that the cure and concussions,
so here's what I would recommend.
Number one,
low level laser has shown to be efficacious to help with traumatic brain injury,
which is a concussion.
Seek somebody out who's got a six 35 not or Meta laser.
It's great.
Nutrition.
Nutrition is fabulous.
So let's talk about a few nutrients you would like eat some protein.
Protein gives an immediate response creating it gives immediate energy to the
brain.
I would do would you alpha lipoic acid,
which is a great anti oxen and Coleen Vitamin D,
zinc.
And here's the big takeaway.
Glutathione.
Glutathione is the body's biggest intracellular antioxidant.
Two years ago,
sports illustrated did a study.
They had a graduate assistant who take the skull off mice,
by the way,
do me a favor,
whether you like to talk or not,
don't ever vote for me to come back as a Ronan cause they beat the bejesus out
of these guys in labs.
So they took the skull off and they found out that this guy was giving everybody
a concussion.
They went over to him that the mice that is and they put in glutathione and it
decreased brain tissue damage by 70% so there's a lot of nutrition and nutrients
to help brain tissue.
He'll get on that.
And here's the biggest takeaway,
Mike.
When you injure your brain injury,
your gut,
it takes six hours after a concussion to have damage to brain.
Your gut becomes leaky.
Six hours.
So remember,
brain on fire means gut on fire.
Gut on fire means brain on fire.
They're intertwined.
So remember when I said before,
if you had leaky gut,
you're more susceptible to a brain injury.
If you damage your brain,
you're more susceptible to a leaky gut.
So it's not just a concussion and it's not just resting,
it's fixing the systems and the body from the inside out and nothing shows it
better than concussion.
So I want to start encouraging people to think if they have any questions to you
know,
come forward.
We'll have some time for that.
But I want to talk now back to the gut.
Um,
bloating.
We talked about it about a little earlier.
Inflammation.
Uh,
you have the six R's.
That was like really interesting if you could kind of walk.
Sure.
So what Michael's referring to,
we spoken before about bloating is the gut has no pain fibers.
So you can't tell if something like gluten is bothering you.
So do you get gas and bloating when you eat?
Jenny are friends,
gay,
gas and bloating.
You have a gut compromise.
If you get a brain fog afterwards,
it means that your brain membranes are compromised.
Think about that.
It's not after lunch,
which you guys haven't eaten yet,
that it's shipped to feign or anything like that.
If you're like lagging,
there's something wrong with the membrane.
The six our program is a program that I designed to enable ourselves to fix the
gut and fix the brain.
Basically the RSR,
an acronym for we have to remove.
So what are we going to remove?
Are you going to take all the things that you're eating that cause a problem
like gluten and things of that nature?
You're also going to use specific nutrients to remove the bacteria.
So when you eat gluten,
it's like your body's on fire.
So if you stop,
all you did was called a fireman.
They'll houses down,
but there's no more fire.
So now you need to start to rebuild it and call the contract.
You don't call the firemen the next day.
So what you want to do is you want to replace with digestive enzymes and
pancreatic enzymes.
You want to reinoculate.
That's the third are with pro probiotics.
You want to repair and regenerate the gut lining with specific nutrients,
and then the doctors should retest you to make sure you've reached clinical
outcome.
And if you have,
great,
let's retain your health.
Because what,
like I said before,
health is wealth.
All disease begins in the gut.
So probiotics,
all these things are great.
New Supplements,
uh,
men and women are very different.
Right?
So,
uh,
you just noticed that.
Yeah,
that's what I would talk later about.
Uh,
tell me.
So,
um,
especially when it comes to bone density and things like that,
what,
what should maybe women be doing differently than men?
Well,
in reference to the bones with women,
I don't think we speak to are 52% of the population.
My counterpart enough.
And what they don't realize,
women are partaking in athletics all the time.
Now.
I mean,
when I went to school,
there was something called,
I think it was title nine women are playing sports.
So what happens is if women get anything that revolves around a eating disorder
or not eating enough food,
they get something called Amen area.
It's a loss of a menstrual cycle.
Lots of a menstrual cycle for three months or longer and not getting one.
This amen.
Aria enables women,
unfortunately to get osteoporosis about a decade earlier.
So women should supplement and eat a good diet and consider calcium.
The best form of calcium,
if anybody's interested,
is microcrystalline hydroxyapatite concentrate.
Don't make me say it again.
MCHC so you want a good form of calcium with a good diet to make sure your bones
are not susceptible to osteoporosis.
By the way,
men at 40,
we overtake women.
We lose 2% of our bone density verse 1% of them.
So we always have to eat well.
We always have to consider supplements and we always have to exercise.
And you have to get a doctor,
you have to get a doctor that's individualizing the treatment for your needs.
You're not a number,
you're a person.
So,
um,
what would you say some of the real key takeaways that you want people to take
away from this book when they read it?
So for me that it's,
it's a few fold if when you guys read it,
and thank you for having me here.
I greatly appreciate that one.
Therapeutic lifestyle is the way to go.
Change your life.
Um,
number two,
what's most interesting is I always,
as I said earlier,
I like people to implement.
So knowledge plus power,
knowledge plus action equals power.
The power is in getting you healthy.
You know the Times that I start to think and I get excited,
I have to stand for this.
I start to think about Norman cousins and he had one of the greatest
motivational lines I have ever heard.
He said the tragedy of life is not death,
but what we let die inside of us.
Why we live.
So do not let your zest for health die.
Do not let your friends asked for health die.
Never.
Health is one of the most important things.
If by any chance you guys are,
you know,
faltering on that are not getting energy.
Trust me,
I am the energizer bunny rabbit.
If you didn't notice that I am it out.
They've gotten me medicated to stay calm.
My Wick Burns three 65 24 seven.
So if you ever need anybody to pump you up,
you come to me.
Cause my Wilco light everybody else's in the room and we'll get outside and
start changing healthcare.
So if you will just remember you can change and you can change tomorrow.
Well said.
Thank you.
Uh,
does anyone have any questions?
Thank you for coming here today.
Um,
I would like to have,
I mean I got your take on gluten but I'm still like not convinced really.
Why really do you think it's bad for you?
And do you have like studies or anything that really shows it?
Absolutely.
Gluten is broken up into two different proteins and those proteins have shown
through,
Oh my goodness.
A lot of different studies to cause.
Um,
deleterious affects bad effects on people's health if they damage the god.
One of the proteins is the one that I referred to a gliadins and in that protein
in 100% of people studied damage to the gut.
Listen,
I understand that you may like bread.
It does taste pretty good.
Unfortunately man makes it.
And what's happened is,
you know,
it's not the same bread that we had 40 or 50 years ago.
I mean you have to understand where it's coming from.
You have to understand where that weeds coming from our soil.
But to speak to gluten,
there is a ton.
I mean I can give you a ton of studies later.
I mean probably 300 if you really want to stay up all night and you can see that
gluten is very deleterious.
What's most interesting about gluten,
and I'm happy you brought that up,
it's a great question,
is that Celiac disease is the height of having new gluten issue by one in a
hundred people have celiac disease and 30% of Americans now are doing a gluten
free diet with no change in a number of celiac disease.
And that's why that six,
our program is so critical cause he got to fix the damage at the Grande does.
Thank you.
Thanks Pete.
Thanks.
That was great.
Any other questions?
We'll have a sandwich later man.
Yeah,
so I have a question.
So,
um,
weight loss diet,
we talked about that.
But,
um,
you have a couple of good bullet points,
you know,
for uh,
we're always concerned about calories and counting calories.
Your take is a little different,
right?
I'm not a big proponent of counting calories,
calories,
it just units of energy.
I want everybody in here to start counting chemicals.
I want everybody to hear,
start counting nutritional value versus calories.
I want everybody to start thinking about if it's made in a plant,
I won't eat it.
But if it comes from a plant,
I'll consume it.
So that's the concept.
Calories or just a basic unit of energy,
but not all the carers.
And the same because when you think about it,
if I took you down the road and you've got a Frappaccino for a thousand
calories,
is that the same if I gave you a fist full of Broccoli?
Not all calories are equal.
So A,
we're on the run a lot.
We don't have time to buy fresh vegetables,
sliced him up,
make a Greek salad every day.
You know,
what are you recommending for people who have a very fast paced job with an
incredibly small amount of time to even eat?
I mean,
I would say most people in this room,
including myself,
we did our our desk if we're working,
you know,
absolutely.
But food,
you know,
food is a potentiator for inflammation and food is life.
So this is the one thing I'm going to say,
plan for it.
I mean,
I lay my clothes out the night,
the day before planned for it and make good choices.
You're fortunate here on Google,
I saw the options you had to have.
Fantastic.
So for the people out there that are watching make better choices.
So for instance,
if you're going to get something on a run,
get it baked,
steamed,
broiled,
don't get it fried.
Make those changes.
Make sure that you eat from the color rainbow.
Eat a lot of Greens.
Start Understanding that your best bet is Greens and protein and avoid sugar.
Sugar is a toxin.
Avoid sugar.
If you just cut sugar out,
you wouldn't be impressed.
In nine days.
There've been studies that have shown if people decrease sugar,
they decreased their heart markers,
adverse hard markers by 50% I have a lot of friends,
myself included,
who can justify eating bad food if I just go to the gym enough or you know,
I mean,
is there a,
can there be a balance?
I mean,
well,
you cannot run a bad diet.
So that's what you should tell them.
Elaborate on that.
Well,
you know,
exercise is great and exercise.
It is his life movement is life.
But when you really think about it,
if you're consuming a lot of garbage and things that are full of calories and
things that are full of chemicals and it out of not true nutrient value,
what's going to happen is you can't outrun it.
You can't overtake it.
So it's that equation of exercise plus Diag,
decreasing stress and enjoying life.
No one,
you know,
the biggest problem that people have when they come,
they think a healthy diet refers to the idea that it won't taste good.
And that's not true.
If anything,
once you try it,
you're gonna love it.
Hi there.
I'm Taylor.
Thanks for coming today.
Taylor.
Just a quick question.
So I'm hearing no sugar,
no gluten,
no leave,
no this,
no that.
Um,
what about the everything in moderation policy or what can we do to sort of live
in the world that we exist in and in a city where we're surrounded by food all
the time.
Um,
that's still like mindful of uh,
you know,
the best health practices.
Well don't make sure you don't eat anything with added sugar.
So we have a problem.
And so for instance,
if you were to look at that food label now since 2014 the food labels talk about
fructose,
but it's not really fructose,
which is fruit sugar.
It's high fructose corn syrup.
So things are mislabeled.
My theory is as long as you can see what you're getting,
you can eat it.
Obviously the leaving the Abil,
you know how I feel about that.
Use some natural supplements.
Try not to eat,
you know,
limit the amount of sugar that you do.
And I mean,
gluten is just basically at this point a true no go.
I mean,
don't shoot the Messenger.
Just be happy.
I'm going to give you the message and it'll be fine.
Life will go on.
Do you know,
again,
any restaurant has a gluten free menu.
Now
what about like,
um,
snacking,
almonds?
You know,
can you give us a list of like some great things that are safe to eat and easy
to get?
Great,
great choice.
Ahmed's are a great choice.
Please have them raw.
Um,
what they'll try and do is they'll try and cook them with like a peanut oil,
which is unhealthy for your soap.
Run nuts are a great choice.
Avocado.
So what do I travel with?
I put hard boiled eggs in their eggs are fabulous.
Some nice cage free eggs.
I carry that around.
I carry some almonds,
I carry some Avocados and leave and carry around some berries.
These are all great choices.
Just it's easy as this eating nonprocessed food diet is your best option.
Eat from the color rainbow.
Enjoy.
No one's asking you to stop,
man.
Makes it.
Jack Lane was right.
Don't eat it.
Did you have a follow up?
Yeah.
You mentioned the meantime getting your protein,
right,
right.
So is there like a Patina should favor or not in particular?
Um,
let's say animal animal protein versus plant plant based protein?
Well that's a great question.
That's one of the biggest arguments in the field plant.
So plant based protein on ball for if you're going to do an animal based,
which I like and I do consume,
you want grass fed beef,
you want grass fed organic beef,
grass fed beef is great at tying Omega threes,
which are healthy fatty acids,
whereas most animals that were exposed to,
if you're going to eat that or make a six very unhealthy for you.
So grass fed beef plant,
great choices for protein,
chicken,
Turkey and the live poultry is great.
Bison.
MMM.
But uh,
I mean I heard that um,
for the,
the number one death because in the u s is a corny
heart disease
and you know,
um,
it's really important not to consume like much fat to Ah,
not get it.
Aww.
I love that.
Thank you so much.
You get a free lunch later for that.
I love that.
It's actually not fat that cause coronary heart disease.
There was a study that came out and it's proven that sugar causes coronary heart
disease,
sugar clauses,
the plaquing,
it's not fat in the problem that we had,
and I hate to say it here,
it just came out two weeks ago that Harvard researchers were paid to say it was
fat that increased saturated fat,
that increased heart attack and not sugar.
They were paid by the sugar industry.
We all know that it just came out.
So you know,
it's not a conspiracy theory.
And if you look at the biochemical pathways,
sugar causes plaquing and coronary heart disease,
fats don't,
fat is your friend.
It is not your foe anymore.
We were not told we were misinformed.
So that's an interesting point about the proteins too.
Just knowing that some of these things are safe and hopefully tailor,
that'll make you feel better too because I definitely made me feel a little
better knowing that I could have some chicken and stuff in.
There is plenty there to choose from,
I promise you.
Um,
did you have a question?
Yeah.
So you said sugar is bad,
but what about uh,
honey that gets shown to be at least some studies show that it's,
it can be very beneficial to the buddy.
Well,
you know,
uh,
my functional medicine docs are definitely gonna kill me cause I'm going to say
if it's pure honey,
it has some medicinal effects.
So I would go for that.
But again,
you're,
if you're talking like an a Gaba,
the way they take it out of the Cactus,
that poses an issue because that functions in a body like high fructose corn
syrup.
So I will tell you that if someone said they want to add a little honey to
something,
I'm not adverse to it.
As long as they're not adding honey to a plate of pasta.
I know that doesn't mix or some other carbohydrate.
I'm not a very good cook.
Everybody.
I cook funny wife once.
Yeah,
I'll lay off the pasta honey on a Bagel.
Then I can just say that.
Uh,
I don't cook much,
but the honey,
if it's a little bit and it's real honey and not manufactured or anything like
that,
I'm going to let you go with that.
How about pure maple syrup?
No,
no dice,
no dice that's out there.
Uh,
my dad has been experimenting last two years with intermittent fasting since
like the greatest thing ever.
And I'm not convinced.
Just wondering what your thoughts are.
I know you talked about like a detox,
I don't know if that plays into it at all,
but just your thoughts on intermittent fasting,
intermittent fasting.
It's not in the book.
Intermittent fasting is very different than what I purport to that a diet
should,
uh,
adhere to.
There's not a lot of literature on it.
People like it.
Um,
I,
for me,
I always tell people to have like an eight or two 12 hour window between that
last meal on that first meal that's not in a minute fasting.
So the literature is really small on that.
And at this point I would avoid the innovated fasting.
Clearly the detox is different and I suggest everybody in this room started
detox program.
Does that answer your question?
Yeah,
it does.
It shock the body,
the metabolism and all of that.
This fast thing,
I just think what they're doing is they're shocking.
The body that cutting their calories and um,
they're just not eating enough.
You know,
it was very funny.
We do need to eat,
we need to consume our calories to have enzymatic reactions.
So eating is good.
It's just,
again,
not the calories we eat.
Is it the chemicals,
what's the nutritional value?
Is their satiety?
Is there a sensation of fullness when you eat?
You know,
when you eat sugar,
your blood,
your blood sugar goes up,
it drops down and then you want to eat more.
And that just has that vicious cycle and blows up from that.
Hi.
Oh,
sorry.
I thought you were standing there first.
Sorry.
Thanks for coming and sharing your knowledge.
I'm shifting the conversation a little bit away from food,
but I wondered if you had any thoughts about um,
people who like cracked her knuckles or their bones pop and how that might
impact how else in your body?
Um,
you mean like why that's actually that?
Yeah.
Um,
if I do it,
it's probably gonna be different than if,
uh,
the layman person does it.
If it goes naturally,
I'm okay with it.
I know when I grew up they said if you do this,
you're going to get arthritis in.
That hasn't been proven.
That's just a little sound in your fingers.
But my opinion would be have a professional do it because you get a better
clinical outcome with that.
But um,
if it goes on its own,
I mean you may be leading to that.
Like if you move around to hear some crackling,
if you will,
that's not bad.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Thanks.
Hi.
Um,
so you talked about the obvious,
you know,
just work out and eat a good diet.
But you mentioned supplementation and I've experimented with supplements in the
past because I'm vegetarian.
So what would you say is the best regimen for someone who doesn't eat as much
meat or fish or dairy or like you know,
obviously you can't have fish oil,
but fish oil is a number one thing that's good for you.
And what's the best regimen for someone like that?
Okay,
well in reference to the fish oils,
what you could do is you could use in algae based fish oil,
so that would adhere with your vegetarian lifestyle.
So why would it be a big proponent of one?
You want to get some protein in it.
A lot of companies now I'll make a peanut rice protein pea and a rice protein
with added amino acids.
Branch chain amino acids has shown to be as effective as way.
So it's a great supplement.
Um,
with other supplements I would recommend for everybody here.
I'll multivitamin multimineral phytonutrient excellent choices do you make a
three is great.
Call Vitamin D,
Hormone d,
outstanding choice probiotics.
Just bathe your intestinal tracks and good bacteria.
Let yourself have plenty of good bugs and make sure you're eating a lot of
fruits and vegetables or a fruit and vegetable mix.
Those would be the standard supplemental recommendations I would recommend for
everybody in here and everybody out there listening,
supplemental to lifestyle,
Diet and uh,
what are some good probiotic foods that people can have?
Vegetarian only or is there no some good foods?
You know,
of course yogurt comes to my beat,
yoginis dairy and people think there's enough probiotics and yard right there.
Millions of bugs,
bacteria,
I call them bugs.
In yogurt,
you need billions.
So you really need,
I hate to say we do need to supplement a,
we're more at pulling out the bacteria.
You know,
interestingly enough,
you had asked me a question about the issue with the medical model and I have a
lot of respect for the medical doctors.
They're fabulous and they're brilliant,
but they spent the 20th century taking bacteria out of our stomach with
antibiotics and now we're spending the 21st century trying to repopulate it.
So you really probably going to have to repopulate with a probiotic.
But a good day,
it's great start and good foods with a have a lot of fiber will feed the
probiotics.
We call those prebiotics in those prebiotics or resistance starches,
they're actually carbohydrates that are cooked,
cooled,
and cooked again,
and then a new thing out there.
And I think the resistance starch is going to be your choice to consume
carbohydrates.
So,
um,
supplements is really the only way we can meet our probiotic,
uh,
needs now,
isn't it?
I mean,
for what we need and where we are.
The only way I've seen it as,
I recommend a lot of probiotics.
Yes,
I do.
But Diet is,
remember the word supplement,
supplemental to what?
Diet,
lifestyle,
et cetera.
Any other questions?
I think that's our time.
Um,
Dr Rob,
this was fantastic.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you to Google for having us.
And,
uh,
we were,
this was wonderful.
The book is inside out health,
but it's up there and thank you so much,
Dr. Tick.
Thank thanks for having me.